that is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK and I'm Dave
Jewett the host of Loadout the Gamespot
show that delves into pop culture's most
iconic weapons and on today's bonus
episode Jonathan's going to be breaking
down the different variants of the AK
rifle from the very original AK-47
design through to the akm a tight 56 and
of course a golden AK because we had to
it's essentially
I mean I hate the word but bling you
know it's it's male jewelry if you like
this kind of content make sure to
subscribe us we have plenty of episodes
of Loadout for you to check out on our
Channel including an episode that dives
into the history and the pop culture
impact of the AK-47
right let's get to it
[Music]
so talking about the very iconic
Aesthetics and this is a genuine
type one AK-47 of the the OG that's
right so that influenced all the the
lines the iconic magazine the the wooden
furniture why don't you uh walk us
through some of them yeah I mean if
what's interesting for people to do in
their own time is um go back and look at
some of the prototypes 1946 sort of time
and see just how many ways you can you
know try and build a better mousetrap
with the inspiration of the German Stone
Rivera but then going in different
direction but this is the um
the sort of build standard that came out
in 1947 and so rifles of this exact
configuration prototypes were which are
the true AK-47s and what they were
trying to do here was a bit of a hybrid
design so
um the What's called the front trunnion
block is all machine steel you can see
that shape there
but then the rest of this receiver was
meant to be this sheet metal that it
works out eventually cheaper to make and
makes the whole gun a bit lighter but
they ran into those problems and we
ended up with this old school machine
block of steel where you remove a load
of metal from the inside of that and
then put your guts in there basically
but this one is 1951 dated I mean really
it looks very similar
once once you spot that shape there you
you can spot a type one also that pistol
grip an early type of plastic basically
checkered with the diamond pattern in it
that's very distinctive so if you ever
see that on an AK there's a good chance
that's a type one and this very smooth
top cover is perhaps another feature and
the slab sided smooth Metal magazine as
well that is an incredible piece of
History though
considering like as we were saying
before this is one of the few things on
the table that you can actually properly
call an AK-47 yeah that's probably the
only one if you twisted my arm I would
call an AK-47 whereas compared to the
rest of what's on the table like we were
talking about before AK-47 became a
catch-all term but this might be
something more this this is more often
shown as an AK-47 in media but this is
the akm
so how would if someone at home wanted
to you know start becoming a little
nerdy about it and look in their
favorite games and movies what details
would they look for to to to figure out
if what they're shooting is actually
an akm or perhaps this type 56. um well
in if you're actually shooting it the
first thing you've noticed is the
decreased weight of the akm because
using that sheet metal really did
lighten things back up considerably even
lighter than the type one oh wow and
that's that's noticeable yeah yeah that
really is a lot lighter that doesn't
help you in in first person view or
third person view or whatever so the
recognition features primary one is
going to be this dimple above the
magazine well both sides whereas on the
classic AK we'll set aside the type one
because they're not common so the
classic AK or AK-47 if you like has that
big Groove milled out of the solid
receiver just to reduce a bit of weight
but it's a really handy recognition
feature it means you're either looking
at a classical
type 2 or type 3 AK
-47
or an earlier Chinese type 56 which is
what we've got here yeah so it says
there's always a caveat to these things
now the one we've got here doesn't have
that Mill receiver because the Chinese
seamlessly went from the old way of
making an AK receiver to the new way of
making one if you really look closely
there are still differences between this
and an akm but it's essentially an akm
pattern gun the big giveaway for the
fixed stock guns like this one is
a built-in Spike bayonet actually there
are there are some that exist that have
the folding stock and the spike bayonet
and they're surprised as the the
so-called double under folder and then
export versions don't always have the
bayonet and the only other way to really
easily tell them apart is well something
to watch out for because it's good in
first person view is a fully enclosed
front sight protector if you compare
that with any of the Russian AKs in fact
the majority of AKs only the Chinese and
the direct copies of those so maybe some
from Iran would have that SKS style
front site other than that it is Tiny
details
um Chinese markings are a giveaway of
course but export guns will have L and D
in the Roman alphabet so and the other
big very gamey thing about AKs is that
quite often a game
will lack of them in Gold what's the
deal with gold and AKs why are they such
like a pop cultury thing but what's the
actual real world reason and it's unlike
this one in particular
why is it gold
well I mean it's generally gold plating
on Firearms you is usually an indicator
of either Middle Eastern origin or maybe
South American some of the drug cartels
in particular are very fond of
gold-plated or Chrome plated
holy hell
this is definitely a cartel Outpost just
some it's essentially
I mean I hate the word but bling you
know it's it's male jewelry there aren't
many gold-plated guns in existence
overall because of course the Tactical
utility of a nice shiny gun that draws
attention to you is nil it really is
just about showing off so this one in
particular came out of Iraq and belonged
to the Hussein family one of a number
that recovered during oh wow yeah
so this is the What's called the tabuk
which is a locally produced AK variant
yes this is a specific shorter Barrel
variant I can see her book yes on the uh
on the top there wow so Yugoslavia the
former Yugoslavia set up a production
line for and with the Iraqis under
understand the same and produced so
actually quite good okay at least at
first
um Quality suffered later on and they
actually came up with their own medium
length version as well which is quite
unique but yeah an unfortunate side
effect of that is that they had the
Yugoslavian style black plastic Crystal
grit which kind of detracts
yeah the overall look it's got very nice
wooden furniture up front and then
believe it or not is also plastic oh it
looks like wood but it's our favorite a
bakelite-esque polymer that really does
look yeah it's effectively a fake wood
this does fit the the bill a little
better than the black though it does but
are they were were some of them actually
gold-plated because it doesn't it's not
heavy like that's actually gold plated
wow don't don't forget gold plate is
like I don't know
it's not quite Nano scale but it's very
very thin so this would actually
function this would shoot just fine and
it wouldn't add more than oh God I don't
know tiny amount a couple of grams
probably to the overall weight of the
thing and I suppose the the Kudos that
started out as a gift
bled into video games as it was kudos
for achieving an astronomical amount of
points with your weapon it's rather than
a gift it's I suppose yeah in video
games it's bling to show off your
achievements right it's all status and
Prestige it's just it's like two
different worlds virtual world real
world I think I like the real version
one the video game version it just looks
so gross in video games I can't help it
but this have like this obviously being
a piece of History
I don't hate yeah it's more yeah it kind
of helps that you know where it comes
from yeah and all of the history and
politics bound up in that and the you
know real life horror of that regime
um it's not something you could ever say
was nice but
yeah significant and and tells you all
you need to know about that sort of
Personality actually yeah thank you so
much for watching this episode of
Loadout if you enjoyed please do like
the video and subscribe and maybe even
let me know in the comments down below
or on Twitter at a regular Dave what
you'd like to see an episode on if you
want more video game Firearms content
you can watch our back catalog of
previous episodes or check out our
weekly series of firearms expert reacts
where I show our friends the Royal
armories a slew of guns to break down
until then I've been your host Dave
Jewett thanks again for watching and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]